l'entraîneur des couguars de montigny
nous faut nous a rejoint arnaud vous
avez un petit pronostic ça vous
intéresse un peu un peu le football
surtout que ce soit en entraînement donc
je vais le voir qui va être là certains
quitteront parkman entraînements n'ont
heureusement
a321 paris paris
on va on va rester quand même dans le
baseball à la saison de division 2
reprend ses droits ce week end avec
votre première journée il ya eu une
intersaison la préparation les ambitions
pour cette nouvelle saison soyons clairs
c'est remonter en élite oui depuis les
mêmes que l'année dernière où ils
remonter en élite donc on va faire on a
on a fait une bonne préparation avant
saison et puis on espère enfin retrouver
l'élite et bien figurer en élite et est
ce que justement retrouver l'élite c'est
pas contraignants en termes de budget
derrière vous c'est pas juste pour
monter vous voulez vous y inscrire sur
le moyen terme si tout à fait donc on a
besoin on a besoin du
l'effectif des joueurs français qui sont
qui sont plus rapides à l'investissement
parce que ces deux trois entraînements
par semaine plus les week-ends et ce2 on
va dire de janvier à septembre octobre
donc ça fait pour des joueurs qui sont
pas professionnels sont complètement
amateur c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup
donc on a besoin de ces joueurs là et
ensuite un petit peu d'argent pour se
renforcer vous pensez que ça coûte vous
êtes au club depuis deux saisons il me
semble depuis 2011 après 2011 et hervé
gt avant en tant que joueur et puis j'ai
fait un gros break de quasiment dix ans
et je suis revenu dont quitte pas les
couverts comme ça et justement vous
voyez le club progressé de saison en
saison vous sentez plus fort le groupe
cette année gil galliot le club en
général et c'est surtout le sait la
volonté des dirigeants c'est que le club
soit vraiment structuré et pas faire un
coup comme peut-être certains clubs
peuvent faire un gros coup monter en
élite mais tout l'argent sur une équipe
mais ce que veulent les dirigeants de
montigny ce que vol pardon c'est
vraiment structuré donc avoir des
équipes seniors des équipes juniors des
équipes jeunes on est notamment n'est
plus tôt plutôt bon dans les dents les
jeunes est justement là pour cette
saison comment vous avez fait pour
améliorer votre effectif je crois que
notamment il ya quelques joueurs
américains qui s'en dit romance et les
cougars commence à se faire connaître
dans le monde entier parce que on avait
il ya quelques années justement voulait
faire un coup en élite dont elle avait
fait venir un très bon lanceur qui
restait chez nous un énorme et on
n'avait pas l'effectif français
suffisant pour avoir un groupe homogène
et donc il est venu un an n'a pas eu de
très bons résultats et lui à part à son
entraîneur a parlé à d'autres d'autres
d'autres joueurs qui lie le radis va
écouter voulait pas passer une saison
ici long qui viennent gratuitement donc
on les a évidemment accepté c'est la
réputation du club qui les a fait venir
tout à fait vraiment c'est ça on plus
jeunes on leur a dit nous on veut bien
vous accueillir mais on n'a pas le
budget cette année pour vous
aider reloger payer un petit peu
logement vous les aider à trouver du
travail ressort chez eux je sais pas
mais ça vient pas de chez nous on les
aide un peu le club évidemment les aides
un petit peu mais pour ce qui es
logement donc on les a on les a aidés
pour trouver un logement mais
le club intervient très peu donc voilà
le coup les cougars se font connaître
dans le monde entier c'est plutôt pas
mal et quoi qu'il arrive vous gardez
pour cette saison votre noyau de joueurs
français et notamment les jeunes qui
viennent et s'est fait remonter des
jeunes et c'est pour ça que peut-être la
remontée en élite prendra peut-être plus
de temps que prévu mais on veut monter
en élite s'y installer et puis un jour
est champion de france faire des coupes
d'europe etc mais ça on sait que ça
prend beaucoup d'investissement et puis
bon depuis beaucoup trop souvent les
jeunes sont formés à
montigny-le-bretonneux c'est un bon club
formateur on a eu l'occasion depuis des
années à de le dire de le redire sur
cette antenne pour autant les jeunes
partent après comment vous allez faire
pour les garder très longtemps au club
et qu'il n'ait pas envie justement
d'aller du côté des états unis eux
quelques joueurs qui sont passés par mon
client qui sont pas tout à fait
plusieurs d'ailleurs plusieurs ce qu'on
veut on leur propose des bonnes
structures après peut-être ça passera
dans le dans le futur par un centre de
formation qui sait des choses comme ça
ce qui est ce qui arrive c'est que les
joueurs notamment les minimes cadets bon
ça a changé de catégorie mais l'équipe
des minimes cadets ensuite il part dans
un pool quand il sort du pôle vu qu'on
est en 2e division et va le rester au
plus haut niveau donc il vaut dans
d'autres clubs mais quand seront ils y
resteront et restons chez nous alors
pour préparer justement c'est mon futur
monte à l'élite vous avez fait une
intersaison un peu particulière puisque
vous êtes parti du côté des états unis
en stage voilà entre guillemets je
dirais on est bien évidemment les partis
aux états unis mais c'est nous on a
monté cette structure avec alex couteau
un ami et puis le club de montigny qui
n'est évidemment tout se reposer là
dessus et on proposait on n'a pas fait
encore une préparation pour les couverts
aux états unis on n'a pas les moyens on
le fera bientôt j'espère mais on a
proposé un stage aux états unis et donc
il y avait quasiment la moitié des
joueurs de mancini qui ont payé pourra
partir à vero beach en l'occurrence et
certains d'autres clubs et d'ailleurs on
fera la même chose au japon cet été se
tartine bretonneux c'est possible non si
les cathares les qatari va l'investir
dans les attentats mais le camp des
loges vient s'installer à saint quentin
en yvelines c'est l'occasion pour être
l'occasion exactement mais ce stage
était aussi peut-être l'occasion de
souder le groupe peut-être tout à fait
on a eu la chance qu'il y avait sur les
30 joueurs à peu près y avait la moitié
de matinée donc c'était très bien et je
vous dis donc j'espère qu'il aura la
même chose au japon enfin on fait la
même chose au japon j'espère qu'il aura
beaucoup de gens de mon kiné aussi puis
surtout j'espère qu'un jour mon ti n'est
la couleur on pourra emmener tout le
monde aux états unis mais viendra nous
voir rassurez-nous vous êtes quand même
pas prêt à sacrifier on en parlait de
cette formation importante au du club à
sacrifier les équipes jeunes au profit
de cette équipe seniors qui pourrait
monter dans les propos de l'arrêt c'est
sale et ce qu'on veut et moi c'est ce
que je vois à montigny on n'est pas en
élite c'est vrai mais le club fait un
gros effort pour avoir aujourd'hui on
est 180 licenciés à peu près pour garder
ses jeunes pour qu'ils aient beaucoup de
jeunes toute façon y'a pas de secret
plus on est jeune plus on aura de bons
seniors donc premier match premier
rendez-vous de la saison c'est ce week
end face à herman fin c'est un monde
tout à fait rage en maréchal ici on peut
fonctionner il faut que ça débute par
une victoire j'imagine ça va débuter par
une victoire les joueurs sont motivés
comme vous dites des états unis said et
même ceux qui ne sont pas allées sont
motivés parce qu' ils feront le prochain
hélas ils sont vraiment motivés ce soir
s'ils sont à l'entraînement bras peu
près de deux heures il a résisté pendant
ont paricipé paris c'est aujourd'hui
sont excusés et on trouve sept avec leur
smartphone pendant le pendant les
frappes
l'entraînement merci à vous merci on
continue cette page de sports anthony on
parle de basket oui le basket club de
guyancourt a vu son label école
mini-basket renouvelé il ya quelques
jours alors en quoi consiste ce label
capron ton du basket à 6 ou 7 ans
éléments de réponse avec patrick chèque
de 10 mais
il n'y a pas d'âge pour commencer à
dribbler avec l'école de mini-basket les
68 ans courtois de 5 à 10 ans apprennent
à manier la balle faire des passes des
doubles pas évidemment souteyrand panier
une panoplie de jeux et d'exercices pour
inculquer aux enfants l'esprit d'équipé
est peut-être fait renaître les talents
de demain le but du jeu c'est de faire
venir les enfants vers le masque est en
créant des jeux autour du basket les
enfants ont besoin de prendre du plaisir
je conçois pas faire venir des enfants
s'ils ne prennent pas de plaisir d'abord
vous les gardez pas le but du label
c'est aussi de les garder
télé fait remonter jouer dans des
catégories ont reçu la fédération crée
de la belle école de mini basket en 2002
puis du en cours là toujours obtenu il
fait même partie des tropes premier club
français labellisés en respectant un
cahier des charges très précis comme par
exemple employer un entraîneur diplômé
d'état malgré la médaille d'argent
derniers jeux olympiques de l'équipe de
france féminine les filles ne se
bousculent pas dans la raquette chez les
baby et les mini c'est à peu près
équilibré plus rendement 10 mois on a
deux filles c'est difficile ici bas
d'ailleurs pour ça parce qu'il faut
quand on recrute des filles des jeunes
filles à guyancourt il ya une grande
diversité au niveau des associations
donc les filles elles vont plus
facilement vers la danse la natation
donc c'est dur de regarder les filles
dans les yvelines sept clubs possèdent
ce label école de mini basket
renouvelable tous les trois ans
et pour conclure ce point sur le sport
ce n'est pas parce que nous sommes mardi
que nous n'allons pas jeter un coup
d'oeil aux résultats
ce week-end avait lieu la 33e édition de
la course du printemps et cela a été un
cru plutôt historique le record de
l'épreuve a d'ailleurs été battu par le
vainqueur grégory cheval licencié à le à
saint quentin il a franchi la ligne
après cinquante et une minutes et 8
secondes de course soit une moyenne de
plus de 17 km heure donc une très très
bonne moyenne il devient par la même
occasion champion des yvelines du 15 km
et quelques 42 minutes plus tard guy cad
à pau en termine à son tour de toutes
les éditions a presque 76 ans il a
bouclé les 15 km en 1h 33 mais pas très
content de lui quand même on les écoute
non denses et un temps de l'unijambiste
sais rien parce que non non j'ai déjà
réussi 06 06 donc quand je vois que je
me traîne là sur des kilomètres bombay
talence marcquois puis
avec là je pars dans les titres de leur
gilet où ça fait mal au genou
je fais tous les jours tous les jours de
la gym et irma demi d'eau
un peu d'alter barre fixe s'est un peu
tous les jours donc qui tire ma colonne
d'eau
de rose et guy kapo n'est pas près de
s'arrêter de courir puisqu'il va
s'aligner sur la grille en course ce
week-end et puis par ailleurs pas sur
les 10km de rambouillet par la suite
football avant paris barça montini
algrange oui c'est un peu moins ça donne
justement voilà c'est un peu moins
prestigieux mais quand même hein c'est
du football féminin 18e journée de
division 2 montigny se déplacer à
algrange en moselle et défaite 3-1
désigné monteyne c'est leur premier
revers en six confrontations directes
pour les joueuses de dany jordanie
grosset qui reste 7e de leur poule de
division 2
au classement vous l'avez dit on passe
donc au roller hockey j'ai du mal avec
ça avec ça
je pense que celle que j'ai bar certes
jamais eu de match excusez-moi rôle
heureux pour lui c'est bien aussi par le
rock et voit la 14e et dernière journée
de nationale 3 les chocs se sont imposés
à domicile face à aubergenville si petit
but à 3 1 facilement de quoi finir la
saison sur le podium du championnat en
attendant le résultat de la rencontre
entre camon et aubergenville donc
direction les playoffs pour les joueurs
de benjamin ferran on reste elle encore
foot us foot us les templiers
d'elancourt n'ont fait qu'une bouchée
des molosses d'asnières samedi soir
victoire nette 42 à 23 des joueurs
d'emmanuel charest toujours invaincu
cette saison ils sont logiquement en
tête du championnat devant le flash de
la courneuve mais on termine avec du
tennis oui un petit résultat en tennis
le club de de bailly noisy a réalisé un
exploit le week-end dernier à l'isra
mais carla à ce n est qu en dise
paillasson des jeunes filles en or
l'équipe 15 16 ans filles a conservé son
titre de championne de france face à
lyon les garçons sont de leur côté vice
champion de france tout va bien pour
bailly noisy merci anthony pour ce point
sur le sport on vous retrouve lundi
prochain nouvelle édition du 7 8 sport
après un long week-end férié du 1er
avril moi je vous retrouverai à demain
18h avec de nouveaux invités nous ferons
une fois de plus le tour de l'actualité
locale en direct donc dès 18h excellente
soirée les programmes qui se poursuivent
sur téléfilm